no hay confirmaciones de una operación
de falsa bandera que occidente denuncia
y que rusia niega por supuesto pero
vivimos un ataque en el este de ucrania
y acusaciones cruzadas que tan volátil
es la situación en esa zona de ucraniana
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
efectivamente la situación es crítica se
han reportado más de 57 incidentes en la
zona en conflicto lo que significa que
es el punto con mayor violaciones al
cese del fuego desde agosto del 2018 los
graneros y las fuerzas de la otan están
acusando a rusia de estar activamente
tratando de buscar una respuesta por
parte de las fuerzas ucranianas de
manera de poder justificar un
escalamiento en las agresiones pero
hasta ahora parece que se han mantenido
dentro de todo han tratado de evitar la
confrontación pero siguen dándose hasta
es una fuera se seguía viendo
intercambio de artillería sobre la
frontera ahora a vladimir putin se
refirió recientemente a la situación en
el donbass como un genocidio qué tan
probable es que el presidente de ruso
utilice justamente la situación de los
rusos hablantes del este de ucrania como
un pretexto para invadir
en el pasado ya lo ha hecho la
intervención en georgia se basó en buena
parte en un discurso basado en el
genocidio supuesto genocidio de la
acción masiva de los derechos de los
rusos en esta zona lo mismo ocurrió
durante crimea se utilizaba el lenguaje
de la responsabilidad de proteger de
manera de tratar de tergiversar este
principio humanitario internacional y
justificar una intervención armada
entonces efectivamente que estén
acusando a ucrania estar perpetrando
violaciones masivas a los derechos
humanos en estos territorios nos debería
despertar a hacer sonar las alarmas como
otro indicio más de que putin puede
realmente estar preparándose para
iniciar una ofensiva ahora rusia asegura
estar retirándose parcialmente mientras
que eeuu hoy sigue insistiendo en que
por el contrario aumentan su presencia
militar en la región que a brad es
escalada o seguirá a vladimir putin
ejerciendo presión para obtener lo que
quiere de occidente en materia de
seguridad
sumado a las declaraciones de bailén
hace unas horas el gobierno del reino
unido también dijo de que putin ya había
tomado la decisión de iniciar los tbi
dades contra ucrania desde que se
anunció el supuesto repliegue alguna de
las fuerzas rusas sobre la frontera
hasta ahora la evidencia indica de que
no ha habido ningún tipo de repliegue al
contrario se ha aumentado la presencia
militar se han fortalecido las
capacidades logísticas y la
infraestructura necesaria para poder
llevar a cabo operaciones militares por
lo cual en el corto plazo no estamos
viendo nada que nos permita pensar de
que realmente putin tiene la intención
de replegar fuerzas y de escalar las
tensiones
considera usted que realmente es posible
considerar este escenario en el cual
rusia estaría preparando o allanando el
camino para justificar un ataque
están todos los elementos para
considerar o para creer de que putin y
está dispuesta a tomar esta decisión
eventualmente y que entonces utilizaría
la violación de los derechos humanos
como un justificativo o un intento de
legitimar acciones militares en ucrania
si va a ser efectivo o no eso ya es otro
punto de debate
y eso no significa que el conflicto sea
inminente están dadas las condiciones si
deberíamos preocuparnos si todavía hay
instancias que puedan ayudar a
desescalar las tensiones y evitar un
conflicto también las hay ahí va a ser
importante las acciones de blink en
sobre todo hoy después de se anunciado
de que iba a tratar de reunirse con su
par ruso en europa la semana próxima